Đầu năm đến nay, tại nhiều khu vực trong cả nước đã sẻ ra mấy lắm loại hình thiên tay,
làm bộ miệng bệnh vui tử vòng mất tích 20 tư mất tích 20 tư mởi bị thường.
Trong đó, báo số 1 vụ tiếp, dù không đồ bộ như người mơ lớn khiến 50 tư vòng 20 tích,
hàng in hết ta hoa mộ và thủy sản bị thiết thải.
Chứ tình gình trên, thu tướng đã ban hành nhiều công định chỉ đạo tập trụ ứng phó với thiên tay,
các bộ ngành và địa phương đã kích hoạt phương án phòng.
Trong thiên tay theo phương trình bốn tại chốt, chỉ vì tại chốt, lực lượng tại chốt, phương tiệt,
bất tư tại chốt, hậu cần tại chốt.
Cô quan lý đeều và phòng trong thiên tay bộ nông nghiệp và môi chường,
phối hợp với các cơ quan lên quan lên chuyện phổ biến, hướng giắn trong người dân chủ động uống phó thiên tay.
Phối hợp với gia lồ Việt Nam người tiên nhắn cạnh báo thiên tay và hướng giắn người dân chủ động uống phó với báo,
mưa lớn, người cơ lũ quét, sặt lợ đất.
Theo Trung tâm dự báo khi tự thị văn cuốc gia,
tự nay đến thằng chiến năm 2020, báo và át thấp nhìn nơi tiếp tục xuất hiện trên biển đông
với tình xuất sắp xí Trung bịng nhiều năm.
Cơ địa phương như hà nội, đàn án, lòng hàn đặt xây dự,
chín khai các phương án bảo đảm án toàn đe điều,
không chình thủy lợi và hệ thống thứ thoát nước trước mũ mở mở báo.